re
うまいなぁ
また君を同源久しぶり
俺どうかしたをた菓子やまた友達の一人がいきなり警察に止められて在留カードみて
くださいって言われたらしいんだよねああああそういうのって最近よく見る米
ツイッターとかでよりもこういう経験あるんだけどさ
その時在留カード持ってなくて草
太田を大変だったよでも今は持ってるよねもちろん
持ってるよ普通にちょっと見せてもらっていいこれ実は見たことがなくてどういうもの
なのか気になってさあねまぁいいんだけどさ
あごめ今の更新があるから今その新生賞と一緒に机の上に置いているこのみせるから
アジャパースポートとか見せてパス等と外国人て常に在留カードかパースポートも
どちらかを持つ必要があるって聞いたことあってあーまあそうだけどさ
家の近くの自販機を使うためにわざわざパースポート
金庫から出したりしないよ俺はじゃあ持ってないんだねはい
持っていません取り調べは以上ですかいやーこれからだね
動画もね実はを取り警察官だ
まじそうして悪いけど今すぐ在留カードかパスポートを提示してもらわないと
俺と一緒に警察署に来てもらうやっぱり端からこの空をかおためにそっと出かけただけ
なんで
ざきてもらおうわかったじゃ
これやっと協力する気になったかッ
って同源これ伝えの t カードじゃうそこをなんとか無理に決まってんだろー明日
からちゃんと持つから
てかこれ俺が方前にかしたやつじゃんおーい誰かのハゲてる外人を捕まえろ
me